hey everyone it's Jeremy your friendly
neighborhood sins narrator and I wrote a
book again it's called the Abel's good
okay last time out I self-published but
fancified it to make it look more legit
this time there's a real publisher and
we've cleaned up the book fix typos and
inconsistencies and we're releasing it
in June ahead of the sequel in September
we've also got some cool pre-order
bonuses like a standalone Abel's comic
book issue concept art alternate covers
and more is it any good well I think so
but I wrote it instead I asked a bunch
of folks who have already read it to
give me their honest opinion yeah great
you'd have superpowers but guess what
you're not because you're able to do a
whole lot with it the main characters
are disabled but also noting that that's
not what defines them as an adult with
cerebral palsy I really loved it because
as a kid I never read books about
disabled people who achieved things I've
actually read the evil three times it
shows that anybody can be a superhero
suck superheroes and like a new
direction they don't really sing the
book is awesome I burned through that
thing so fast and I finished that book
within about Tuesday it has the belief
that no matter who you are you have the
power to make the world a better place
I love it that characters with
disabilities to be portrayed in such a
positive way I cannot wait for the
sequel I truly love the Able's and I
look forward to the sequel strings I
cannot wait for it to be re-released so
I can get the new copy plus the comic
the disabled kids are not only surviving
the story but the heroes of the story if
I would have been a kid when the book it
came out it would have easily been my
favorite book it is something that I
have shared so many times with my
friends and my wife how much I love the
book that she immediately wanted to read
it as soon as I was done with it and she
loved it as well a great play great
characters interesting twists if you're
interested please go to the Able's
book.com pre-orders help authors a lot
because they let bookstores know there's
interest in a certain title I'd be
thankful if you took the plunge and
pre-ordered the Abel's after you do go
register at the Abel's book comm to get
your pre-order bonuses
[Music]